hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
on july 17 2019
nasa stem engagement tweeted out this
emoji math puzzle to celebrate the 50th
anniversary of landing on the moon
if you solve this problem you will also
get the year in the 1900s in which all
three apollo 11 astronauts were born
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
now before i get to the answer i just
want to mention that since
2016 i posted about two similar type
problems per year and they're some of my
most popular videos
i wanted to mention this because i think
you'll enjoy solving these problems too
so how can we solve nasa's puzzle
let's first substitute letters for the
emojis we'll write a for astronaut
m for moon
r for rocket and e for eagle
we now convert this puzzle into math
equations
the first line states that a plus m is
equal to 45
we then have a plus r is equal to 32
r times e is equal to 14 and m times e
is equal to 40.
we want to solve for a times e minus m
let's get started with these two
equations
in fact let's swap these two equations
and we'll subtract the second one from
the first
we get e multiplied by the quantity m
minus r is equal to 26.
we'll put this equation to the side and
now we'll consider these two equations
let's subtract the second equation from
the first
this will cancel out the variable a
we then have m minus r is equal to 13.
and this is good because we can
substitute this into the equation e
multiplied by m minus r is equal to 26.
we then get e multiplied by 13 is equal
to 26 which means e is equal to 2.
from here we'll be able to solve for the
rest of the variables very quickly
from the equation m times e is equal to
40 we can deduce that m is equal to 20
and from a plus m is equal to 45 we can
get that a is equal to 25.
so now we need to solve for the value of
a times e minus m
we have 25 times 2 minus 20.
we also need to remember the order of
operations that multiplication takes
precedence
so 25 times 2 is equal to 50 and then 50
minus 20 is equal to 30 and that's the
answer so we go back to the puzzle and
we get the answer of 30 which means all
three astronauts were born in 1930
this is a great puzzle and will also
help people remember which year neil
armstrong buzz aldrin and michael
collins were born in
thanks nasa for sharing this fun emoji
math puzzle
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube thanks for watching and
thanks for your support
[Music]
you